okay cool yeah you're good you ready you
ready to do this
yeah are we live
yeah we're live now
yep
i went ahead and
oh hi that's a good icebreaker there
but yeah i went ahead and went live at
five and uh we already have people
posting questions and stuff but people
are jazzed about this
yes
yeah hell yeah so i mean dude first off
like congratulations i mean
to see it's been cool to
be in comedy long enough to like see
people
go from open mic to like television you
know and i remember when you came up to
atlanta from florida you were
immediately someone i was like oh yeah
that kid's that kid's gonna pop i mean
yeah you know
so it's been cool to see you go from
like atlanta open mics to then you move
to new york first is that what you did i
went to la for a couple years after
atlanta
had a had a bad time in l.a didn't like
it and then moved to new york
it's just not for me man it's not really
a fun place to be if you if you like
doing uh stand-up
and like if that's where you get your
energy from you know
so because if you're a guy who's not
like
famous or are on the precipice of being
famous la doesn't have a lot of stand up
to offer you
unless you put in like a decade or
whatever
whereas new york there's
tons of stage time at every at every
level depending you know you can be an
open mic or whatever you are
there's a you know a solid 30 40 rooms a
week that you could potentially be
hitting
how how like how bad did it get like as
soon as you went out there were you like
oh no
yeah pretty much well i went out i went
out there after get after doing just for
laughs
um i moved maybe two months after just
for laughs new faces
and you know thinking like oh i got this
heat behind me i'm like ready i'm
gonna get i'm gonna get all this love
and uh
la has has a real way of making you go i
am not
you know
i got there and i was like oh damn
everyone here has done new faces years
ago everyone did new faces years ago
everyone did new faces this year
it doesn't matter you know
you're competing with people who've got
their faces on on billboards on sunset
so you say
why are you going to get no no one's
going to book you right
and then i did
kimmel and that made it a little bit
better but not
not that much better
that's la that's la you do late night
and then it's like all right well
do you want to do an open mic now like
what are you doing right
what are you doing
who gives a what you did
whereas new york is like come on we
gotta come on in you know
yeah wow
yeah i remember i remember when you did
new faces i actually i was up there for
that i was watching it with i was
sitting with noah garden schwartz
another atlanta comic yeah i remember
you did i remember um
was it george wallace was hosting and he
left his notes on stage
yeah
and one comic like rose them about it or
whatever um yeah
that's a legend
you've always been like you went from
florida to atlanta and then you're like
all right i'm just gonna go to la and
then new york like what
how are you because that's something
comics are
definitely always thinking about like
personally me i'm happy to be in atlanta
i've always wanted to just build it from
atlanta and really just create a
foundation here and then kind of branch
out from there but so many comics are
like when should i move to l.a or new
york or like how to even make that
decision like how what how are you able
to like make these big
decisions
and like what's your thought process
behind them
well i mean it helped that i was um
pretty young i was like 23 but i moved
to l.a so i didn't have anything
holding me to atlanta or florida for
that matter
um didn't have a family or anything
um
and
yeah i mean when you're trying to to
pursue comedy and stuff
you're sort of trying to build a fan
base and and
it it's the logic says that that
going through the industry is kind of
the the way to do that at least
that was the logic
you know six seven years ago when i when
i moved to la
now things have changed though so you
can kind of build a fan base from
wherever with social media and tick tock
but that was my my logic i was like well
i got you got to go to one or the other
and
my management was all in la
and everyone at just for laughs they
were all telling me like ah you'll get
you'll get cast in a sitcom you're like
a young ethnic guy i didn't have a
mustache back then they're like you're
like a you know ethnically ambiguous
kind of
not uh threatening
right you should go to la and i was like
yeah you're right i kind of i bought
into it and i went and it was just it's
not the case you know you have to there
has to be
more than that superficial
thing
in l.a
gotta keep on l.a but the truth
is you can't just be a be like a guy who
like checks the box of like oh he has
ethnic his
this is that because that'll get you
into meetings that'll get you into rooms
but that that's it like you all you have
to possess like a deeper
lanes there's like a deep
like a core inside of you
that can jive with the la mindset and
the la like
i don't know the networking there that
happens there's there's something that i
just don't have and a lot of a lot of
stand-ups don't have i think most
stand-ups don't happen but stand-ups are
kind of like weird neurotic people
um
yeah so people who make it in la based
just on stand-up i really respect them
it's like very hard to do
what what's the uh the living situations
because i've known people that moved to
l.a or new york and they're living on a
couch or like what what what was that a
hustle like for you
yeah it was that that that was really
rough um i went there went to l.a
without a place to stay
i literally i just took my mom's toyota
camry and drove from atlanta to la
and
because that's how i moved to that's how
i moved to atlanta actually i did that
same thing
i took it was my car and i drove to
atlanta without a place to stay and i
just figured it out i ended up staying
with samantha severin
very funny atlantic comedian for sure um
basically the same thing happened i
moved to l.a and i stayed i crashed with
a bunch of people a lot of people you
know john michael bond
[Music]
and
eventually i i landed
in this
place in the valley this town called
panorama city and it's like really far
from la
and it's
it was just kind of miserable i was very
miserable when i lived there and then i
lived i lived in a shed for a while and
that was actually the best situation i
lived
um for like six months i lived in this
beautiful neighborhood called silver
lake really pretty
real like hip and cool in east l.a uh
but the place i was living was it was a
back house
which is a it's i think it doesn't
really exist outside of the west coast
but it's just like a kind of like a
carriage house right except like
shittier
yeah more like a shed for real and it
was a back house behind another house so
there's
two houses in front of me and mine was
like down the hill and it didn't have a
bathroom and it was basically just a
room
it was like it was like a storage
facility kind of
and you open it and it's just like a
like a straight shot very small
enough room for like a bed
um
and i lived there for six months and i
mean i had a pretty good time there that
was actually
it was it was my it was my strange
little temple
um and then i got a job working for
hassan minaj writing for him and then i
moved to new york so i was only there
for half a year but
yeah that was that's pretty rough the
place i lived in a place before that too
that that there was like a black mold
problem at a certain point
and that was pretty bad but um
yeah
rough now now thank god i just i live
with my wife in a home with a bathroom
oh congratulations indoor plumbing wow
yeah thank you married up yeah yeah yeah
yeah man you know what they say you get
married you get a toilet
dude that's so crazy that you are living
in a shed behind the shed behind a house
that and then
you
get a job with hassan minaj
yeah
yeah how how what what how did that come
to be because i mean i always saw you
and performed and i was like yeah i mean
it's only a matter of time for him but
then to hear you like i got just for
laughs now i'm living in a shed oh now
i'm working for hassan minaj you know
it's kind of like these peaks and
valleys of the the comedy
journey that most people don't
are aware of or that don't want to
accept of those that want to actually
pursue comedy but
like your story is like that's it's a
lot of up and downs so like when did the
samanage thing happen like how did that
come to be
right so i mean
the the
the issue was was just sort of with um
what i wanted to do when i first moved
to la the thing that i wanted to do was
write in a room i was like i want to be
a writer i want to write for a show
and
because
all my favorite comedians did that all
my favorite comedians wrote on tv shows
at some point so i was like i want to do
what they did and then you know build up
the stand up sort of after that when i
have like a foundation um and like some
savings and stuff because they pay very
well writer's rooms
um yeah so i did i while i was there
being miserable living in sheds and
stuff i was working on packets the whole
time working on
writing packets which are
you probably know
it's kind of like a um
it's sort of like a job application for
for comedy shows they'll have writers
put together
like maybe three to ten pages of jokes
based on prompts jokes based on your own
ideas sketch ideas stuff like that and
and it's dependent on the show so if
you're doing it for colbert it'll be
like come up with some ideas for stephen
colbert to do right
um and then if it's like fallon you're
like
do like a come up with an idea that
involves like a scrabble board or some
stupid
and um i did that with an idea you had
got rejected there that sounds like oh
several so every idea i've ever had
all this packets got rejected never
never got any of them except for hassan
hassan was a packet that was
um
[Music]
really
a good fit because it was about politics
and it was about
islamic issues and muslim stuff and and
and um
it was sort of like john oliver which i
had already gotten pretty far in a john
oliver uh writing process i almost got a
job there
um
so i kind of like felt a little bit more
confident going into that and then yeah
you know praise god i got i got an
interview with with us and from it and
um
yeah then i got the job and it was over
zoom
and uh which was a thing that didn't
really exist back then but i was like oh
god an interview over zoom what is this
yeah and that's actually when i grew out
my mustache
was for that interview because i wanted
to seem a little bit
older and more mature
really
yeah because it was my it would have
been my first job really ever before
that all i ever did was delivery work
and
sort of like manual not not even manual
labor just just
by being a bike boy
um
so i wanted to seem like a more of an
adult so i grew a mustache
and um i think i think maybe it helped i
don't know i've kept it ever since yeah
you got the job so there you go yeah
yeah yeah oh that's good oh yeah uh
quentin said the shed made you stronger
so that's good yeah it
it really did i did i probably did the
most amount of like growth internally
when i was living in that shed
i was listening to that new con that
album by kanye yay about him being
bipolar i was just listening to that
vibing just feeling myself
yeah i got powerful
through the shed
what's that i want to tip live in a shed
live in a shed you got to do it you
gotta do it
um
oh and uh
carter bryant said
you're a beast and the black panther
joke was interesting
uh
interesting where i'm curious about how
he knows about the black panther joke i
don't know if i ever put that on is this
just from a live show this this i don't
know comment because i don't think i
ever
put that on a video
but okay it's interesting i'll take that
backhanded compliment
but it may be
um i don't know
yeah interesting is an interesting way
to um describe it
is interesting
but he's a big fan of the show i mean
he's a comic
um so i think he meant it as a
compliment but all right so like part
part of what you've done
i know we're gonna get to y'all's
questions in just a sec well i want to
get a little more context just because
um
i haven't talked to you in so long but
like how i know
when does all that the the comedy
central stuff happen cause it seems like
you've done like a few you just dropped
a special with them but it seems like
you've done
a few projects with them leading up to
that
yeah um
i
did a sort of like um
like a little web series with them when
i first moved to la i mean i was doing
things like it wasn't all misery in los
angeles it was it was just sad for me
because stand up is what i love more
than anything and that is a thing that
you just have to put on pause when you
move there for the first like year or
two years because you just don't do it
very much
but in the meantime i was i was doing
these packets and i i built a
relationship with comedy central at that
time
um
through my manager and
sort of started meeting
uh the different executives and the
different sort of people with any with
positions of like making things and
booking shows and
um
it was a very slow process but
i think
yeah
yeah i did i did this little web series
with them and i helped with my friend
ahmed weinberg he also had a web series
with them
worked on both of those in a very
informal way
um
and then i just you once you become a
person that's on their radar that's
somebody that
they find funny and that they know is
dependable
and that they know is like cool like not
gonna be a dick about anything
then they'll just you know
when the time comes they'll hit you up
for like a set or or
um in my case i got a longer set which
is cool
but um it's really kind of random it's
just like a matter of of being around
and being well liked
and it's not even remember what i said
like you need to sort of have like a
weird lanes to succeed i don't have that
and yet comedy central still like kept
you know they would still come back to
me because they like me just as a guy
right they're not like oh this dude's
like gonna be the next
dane cook or whatever they just view me
as like is a funny guy and we want to
work with them which is if you can be
that then that that's can can end up
being good enough
i mean that applies at every level too
like even on an open mic it's like you
want to get booked on a showcase it's
like be funny and be nice
like
be a person people want to be around so
it can apply all the way to like up to
comedy central or even just like in your
local comedy scene like being
photographed nice goes a long way
for sure for sure
oh carter heard it on a live show he
said sorry oh
no no problem it prop
is carter in atlanta uh i guess he was
in atlanta he said it was new york or
atlanta when he saw it
i don't think i ever did it in new york
it must have been atlanta because
because i wrote that joke when it that
movie came out and i was living in the
shed when that movie came out
no when that movie came out i was living
with six other comedians in echo park la
there was there was like a two month
window where i lived with six comedians
in like a two bedroom
three bedroom in la it was a nightmare
good guys a bunch of really good dudes
um
opie opia
he actually just uh sold the show to
hulu a week ago
but he was one of my one of my six
roommates oh and i was i was doing that
black panther joke and i probably
visited atlanta and did it yeah yeah
yeah i stand by that bit
dicks
good night
no six is bad yeah the shower was like
a killing field it was disgusting
awesome all right well let's
let's uh let's get into some of the hot
breath versus questions here that is the
hot breath the verse
come on now
we're doing it i like it i fixed my hair
for this yo we doing it oh i mean me too
i tried
fresh off a special
let's
get in to their questions this is an
interesting one
um this cat was actually early he was
super jazzed about that his name his
name is ahmed
and he has
he has like a two-part or i don't want
to
white splain ahmed i'll just say it the
this dumb way and mispronounce it i just
your whole special opens up with how do
you actually pronounce your name so now
i feel like
a white honkey is saying ahmed
dude do whatever you can i think we just
yeah
there's no reason to try because also if
people try especially with ahmed a lot
of the times people they try and they
actually get it even worse right
like oh i'm gonna be i'm gonna be really
authentic let me say it right ahmed and
that's wrong there's no
there's nothing so
you're saying it right joel for joel
you're saying it right okay i feel
better now
so
he um
he accepts a two-parter here
he asks
um what it's like being
muslim in today's industry and how do
you avoid
like type casting
well i i mean i think being a muslim in
in show business
it's this is a good time this is a good
time i think it's been
uh
you know i have to give props to the to
the og muslim
uh actors and comedians from back in the
day in the early 2000s
you know even in the 90s and stuff
uh they they definitely were
working with a lot less
right these people people like ahmed and
stuff
um they get typecast mazda bronte he's
like played a terrorist like 70 times on
tv
i am lucky because
the past like probably six years
um
being a muslim is a bit more of a it's a
benefit it's not really a liability
anymore because people are very
interested in
hearing from minority voices
uh in in show business right
and i i mean that broadly within the
within stand-up which is a little bit
more
what i what i
care about
i feel like
the same thing is kind of true but when
it comes to typecasting
it's great because you sort of have
control over that you know as a stand-up
comedian you have complete control over
what you say right
so it's just a process as a comedian of
of
learning
how to talk about your own issues as a
muslim
and then
learning where your line is like how how
when am i like when am i like kind of
veering into hack territory when am i
doing something that's for me what am i
doing something that that i'm better
than or or that's like creative you know
what i mean um
and then eventually you stop doing you
stop talking about being muslim i think
or at least i did i talked about it a
lot when i
you know first few years when i was
living in florida doing stand-up and
then in atlanta i talked about it a lot
because it was sort of the only weapon
in my in my utility belt
um
but
now i talk about it you know and
especially i probably talk about it for
like six minutes out of the half hour
um
like about being muslim muslim like
actual jokes about it
and it's you know you just grow right
because
you're not
it's not like being black in america
where there's like
a really large population of people that
consume comedy that are black and that
has this huge impact on the culture
right being muslim it's very niche it's
kind of obscure so
if you talk about it too much
you could end up hurting yourself
because people will go oh yeah that's
the guy who talks about being muslim
only and
so he's he's really good for people
named named ahmed and people named
muhammad and mahmoud
and zainab
but anyone else isn't going to be a fan
so you got to be careful with that
because because it's not we don't have
the same cultural cachet in america
really you know
which is good and bad you know
yeah
nice well i hope that helps there i'm ed
and he said fast
so cool oh hell yeah very nice
um
the next question
is um austin perkins
he's in gainesville florida he said i
know
he said would you come back for a show
dude i'd love to go to gainesville i'd
love to go back it's been it's been
years since i've performed there
trying to think last time i went uh
i think i did rocky's dueling piano bar
which was one of my one of my haunts
with my old haunts
i would go to i would do rockies every
wednesday can i ask austin are they
still doing rockies
uh yeah yeah yeah responds and um i
guess he's with the dunce cat comedy
i don't know what that is that sounds
like something new maybe
oh yeah you're an old head now you're an
old isn't that interesting it's crazy i
was like a little kid when i was in
games i was 18. i was like legit like a
child
i mean i guess legally an adult but how
old are you now yeah
i'm 29
you're 29 so you've been how long you've
been doing comedy
this will be my 11th year in october
whoa
yeah man how about you
i'm
34.
i've been doing it 12 years
yeah i mean we're comparable yeah yeah
yeah i didn't really i didn't realize
you were 29 i remember i just i don't
know i said you're just a little kid but
that mustache really gets you
that's what so you think you look at me
like i'm a little kid still kind of i
mean i just see you as
younger i guess just because
in the atlanta scene
i don't know i don't know but i i was
never really like tapped in i mean i was
off doing like the hood rooms and just
being white boy joel you know i went
i was never like
the cool kid you know but i was always
aware of the funny cool kids
was i a cool kid
you were definitely a cool kid
you were nice yes you were in there you
were doing all the cool shows for sure
because you're funny for that you know
sure thanks man that's really sweet no i
mean that's why atlanta is a great place
to be is because
people you know recognize you
and you don't have to be like
hustling for for
10 years straight
people they'll notice that you're funny
and they'll be like you're funny and and
you want to do this show you want to do
that you know what i mean it like
happens like pretty quickly um
yeah whereas big cities bigger cities i
should say la new york even chicago like
there's a lot they put a lot more
hoops up for you to jump through
yeah
yeah and uh austin said rocky's is gone
no
dude i love that place
that's the first place i ever like
hosted a show
oh yeah what were those actual
yeah yeah well they were like little
keyboard pianos it was like a real
keyboard it was okay
yeah yeah they were kind of made of like
some like you know fabricated substance
it wasn't they weren't like legit pianos
it was a bar for for
like drunk
30 year old
to 50 year olds that were like really
ripped and on steroids it was kind of an
awful place but
i had a lot of fun there
your old haunches
oh yeah
we all do them
did you ever do any hood rooms
while you were in atlanta
not really i kind of feel
a bit of
shame about that
um i mean i i also was only do i was
only in atlanta for like two and a half
years so and i was doing a lot of
regional shows like leaving it you know
what i mean chattanooga
south carolina hitting up uh savannah
stuff like that so i was kind of like
trying to be on the road a lot i didn't
um
jump into the hood scene very much
which i don't know if i should be if i
if i should be ashamed of but i feel
shame not you were working i think a
common theme is that you're always doing
something like the like your success and
opportunity
none of it's come by accident like you
you've always been proactive you're
living in a shed but you're like
applying like writing packets you know
and like you're yeah yeah you're always
being proactive and not trying to find
an excuse or complain but really just
like just putting in the work
yeah i mean you kind of have to you know
you have to figure out your um
figure out your limits and and just try
to like hit
go go as hard as you can before without
hurting yourself right yeah because
everybody around you is trying really
hard
ideally
um i know i know
there are situations people can get in
in comedy where they surround themselves
with people that aren't trying that hard
and that's like
that's a bad
that's bad yeah you you want to be
feeling very competitive with your
friends
even you know even with love but like
yeah
you got to be trying hard
yeah because some people use open mics
for just like a hangout and whatnot and
that's cool i mean oh my god if that's
what you want to do go for it i mean but
if you want to be like a comedian and
develop and excel
you really need to surround yourself
with
people that are doing what you want to
do and really staying out of your
comfort zone like it yeah it's a big
part of it like you said having that
circle that really motivates you
totally and i mean also there is there's
a big problem with open mics in that
they
you you have to be
you have to be realistic about what
you're doing when you're at an open mic
right
like when i so i don't really
not to not to be bragging i don't really
do them anymore
but when i lived in l.a i did them all
the time because it was the only place
to get up truly i'd maybe have one book
show a week and then that's not enough
like i want to be getting up every night
right so i'd go to open mics and open
mics in la are
brutal like they're like nowhere
else
and i've done them in i've done them in
new york i've done them in atlanta i've
done them in gainesville
they're worse than gainesville open mics
austin like la mics are rough bro
and
i had to stop myself at a certain point
after i did kimmel and was still doing
open mics
a friend of mine actually did he had to
tell me he was like
like what are you getting out of them
actually like are you are you really
are you just doing it to scratch that
itch or are you
actually getting better at comedy by
doing them
because
a lot of the times open mics like they
can you can get new material out of it
you can get a new joke to work
you can have friends that go there but
it's not actually benefiting you outside
of that and you can delude yourself into
thinking that it is because it's
it's hard work like open mics suck like
they're right we're hard on your ego
they take all day
um
so you can kind of get done with them
and be like damn i i like put in the
work today
but
like did you you know what i mean it's
the same thing as like
like working like a long shift at
a grocery store right
that's like it is hard work it is harder
work than the ceo of that grocery store
is doing that's true
and god bless you
but you're not
moving your career forward necessarily
by doing that 12-hour shift your and of
course it's not totally a fair
comparison because people have to work
to live so that's a different thing
but
compared to open mics and stand-up
sometimes if you're really hustling with
the mics which i was when i lived in
atlanta i did
so many i was doing all kinds of weird
mics everywhere
um
and
when i moved to la i kind of had to
realize like these aren't always gonna
push you forward you know sometimes it
could just make you feel like and
you wasted three hours when you could
have been working on a pilot or working
on um
you know literally just writing jokes by
yourself
yeah sometimes that's better than trying
it on an upper mic sometimes yeah for
sure there are some rooms that you go
whatever i say into that microphone
will will be bad no matter what i say
into it and then it's like well then
don't do that don't do that show
or that but that starting out though i
think you gotta go anywhere and
everywhere
like i think i've gotta be
on a state like i would do karaoke
nights yeah i would just do comedy
middle karaoke nights and like stuff
like
i mean early on i think i think there is
a point
where you do get diminishing returns
when you hit a certain level but like
early on you've got to live on stage i
mean you just need to know what it's
like to stand in front of a room
and try to be
like coherent you know
that's a lot of those early years is
just standing there and getting
comfortable with people staring at you
that just takes a lot of reps
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah what i'm
talking about with like is this taking
me further i'm referring to like
when you're five years six years seven
years in and you've kind of got some
things under your belt maybe you've done
late night maybe you've written for a
show maybe you've you know what i mean
when you've developed a little bit more
that's kind of what i'm talking about
you're right the first like
three to five years you should just
absolutely be
bombing in all sorts of
locations and all different kinds of
groups of people thinking you're
terrible
truly just so you can feel that and go
oh wow
what
what is your worst bomb like have you
been booed or anything
oh yeah man i i um
i talk about it in my special a bit the
worst
one of the worst shows i did i got
attacked
um a lady threw a drink at me
that was in new york actually that was
like
2018.
so it wasn't a mic but it was like it
could have been it was it was a rough
show the worst show i ever did was was
in um little rock
arkansas no jonesboro arkansas
um
and it was just it was at this like
barbecue
restaurant and the room was full and
they
just i was pretty new i was like maybe
three years in do you know um do you
know ben palmer
oh for sure palmer trolls
hilarious comedian for me came up with
him yeah
yeah yeah such a funny guy and he
brought me to the show
and he was like you need to be mexican
for this for the show
because yeah it was it was a it was a
hood
room it was a black room
and uh but it was like it was in
jonesboro arkansas it was like kind of a
weird situation
um it wasn't like a club it was in a
barbecue restaurant
and
and i was really new and as i've already
said i didn't do a lot of black room so
i was like
i don't know what to expect like this is
going to be kind of different from what
i'm used to
because i talk about being muslim
especially at that time i talked about
being muslim a lot
so i was like i don't know if this is
going to be
the same
like is this going to be the same
context
and now i know it kind of is but it also
kind of isn't black you know black
americans have a different relationship
to muslims than white americans so the
jokes didn't
make any sense really
and it just bombed so purely it was like
a pure
it was like something from a movie it
was so rough
people
somebody like jumped on stage and like
did like a like a backflip in front of
me just to like ever it was like a
nightmare it was crazy
the host was like
do the nae nae and i was like what
and i was like what and i was so like
naive and young and
and just not with it i guess and i was
like what is that and then everyone was
like oh
he doesn't even know what that and
i was like i don't i don't know what's
going on
it was rough man
somebody was like
[Music]
i did like an impression of a terrorist
exploding it was the worst night of my
life wait
it's the worst night of my life and
you've lived in a shed for six months
yeah
bro did you did you tell him you were
mexican or like
did you yeah i did
did so did he so
did he tell you this before putting you
on the show are you like driving to
arkansas and he's just like by the way
uh you're mexican for this gig
he gave me notice he gave me about a
week's notice he was like hey can you do
the show with me in arkansas
and it was one of those situations
every comic comes to where
a another comedian will give you an
opportunity
because you have a car
and like
you you don't know that that's why
you're getting the opportunity
until you're six hours into the drive
and you're like oh i see what's going on
like
but
that's that's kind of what the situation
was and ben was like but are you can you
just pretend to be mexican because they
want a white guy and a mexican i was
like i can pretend yeah
and in a paid well i paid like 300 bucks
which is crazy
and
i got there and this is how lazy i am i
was like i'm just gonna say i'm mexican
and then just do my act
because there are mexican muslims
probably
and um
i didn't buy it they're like they're
like no this is whatever this is just
wrong
and
i got off stage and i'll be honest with
you people were
pretty nice to me afterwards like it was
silence for 10 minutes straight
silence
except for the people shouting things
and jumping on stage right they the
crowd looked at me like
like a clockwork orange like they were
just like shocked
at what was going on
and then afterwards everybody was like
hey that was pretty good man it was it
was weird
weird night
and so i got off stage then i go to this
i go to my car i get into the go to go
to my car and sit down just to like
decompress
and then these cops came up to me and
they knocked on my window and they're
like you're not allowed to sit in your
car in in jonesborough arkansas it's
like against the law
to sit in your car at night and i was
like
oh so like they forced me to go
back into the place where everyone just
saw me
piss my pants on stage basically
oh and then everyone was pretty nice to
me yeah
they get all their people out while
you're up there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
comedy's weird like that like you you'll
do the worst thing ever and then
you'll feel like you you're
a criminal and then everyone around you
will be like
hey man can i get a picture you're like
why
oh you know what i mean like there's a
lot a lot more niceness than anything
else in the actual room even if you suck
yeah
at least your face brought you back
there i'm glad we could relive that with
you there
by the way you're mexican i just
i just
yeah
by the way
can you be mexican for this i know all
of your material
is about being muslim and you're three
years in
like
so many factors
for like
that young comic hustle oh my gosh
that's hilarious
god um
there's some mexican comedians he could
have asked some mexican comedians
that's a good point
they took food out of their mouths
that i had a car
they probably at cars
ben we need to bring ben on we need to
intervene
have an intervention with ben i'll
definitely ask him about that have you
do you follow him he's like he's like on
tour like selling out doing his like
slide show
blowing up i know it's it's incredible
it's incredible man he just stuck with
it i knew him in when i lived in los
angeles and he was he was also living
there
and i remember we were we were like
brothers in in misery we were both like
what are we doing here like what is this
place it sucks it's
like we're not gonna make it and now
he's doing great and i'm i'm doing all
right and yeah man
yeah he uh you stuck with it
yeah he would be like for his
like when he back when he was doing just
like fake facebook pages and stuff i
mean he would be at like an open mic on
his laptop just like typing furiously
the entire like he was always working on
that stuff so now to see it like a tour
and he has like a fan base it's uh it's
it's a lot of fun to see happen
yeah
it's it's incredible because it timed up
perfectly with with tick tock you know
like he is
so talented and
i really you got to watch him like try
and learn and grow in in his art as like
the the um
what's it called troll you know the
thing we're talking about the trolling
yeah we got to watch him like learn how
to do that and then learn through the
different apps like how it works on
instagram how it works on facebook and
now on tick tock it's like the perfect
mechanism to like actually translate
into shows you know
yeah yeah
i'm seeing a lot of people yeah like
building like you said earlier i mean
the online fan base and social media
it's like
it could be overwhelming especially with
like like a newer comic dude i
i just did a show
and a comic did really well and i was
like oh nice set that was awesome he's
like yeah but i i forgot to film it so i
didn't get a clip and i was just like
dude this is a new comic i think he's
been in it like a year and i was like
just be funny fer like have something
you want to share and like you don't
have to share every grainy crowd work
clip you ever have like yeah
but i say that
as the old head 12 years in who's like
you don't just you know get good at
comedy first but for them newer comics i
mean
that's part of stand-up now is that you
record it and you post it and then hope
it goes viral like that's part of the
resume now i know isn't that crazy i i
do feel old when i think about it like
that because when i started
it was like
do stand up
get on late night
get a special
get fans
and now
now none of it is like that now it's
like have fans
do a special
be on panel on late night
be in an avengers movie it's like
just so jumbled up you know
it's crazy but it's in our hands i mean
the power's in our hands but it is
it's just gosh
yeah i even like comics like earthquake
just have you seen earthquakes new
comedy special
i started it i didn't get to finish it
though but i love earthquake did you not
did you not like it
no i did i did i i just didn't have i
didn't have time i started it i watched
like five minutes
and then i had to go but yeah i like
ruth baker i'll definitely finish it
he's so funny yeah we we we broke it
down on here and um he was doing like 11
11 laps a minute
oh my god the whole set
geez
it that's that's insane
yeah it we yeah we had a member of the
hot breath verse chris grulon like
analyzed it and broke it all down and
shared the math of it and like it it's
but i i brought up earthquake because
he's one of those old school comics who
was like i'm just gonna get undeniably
funny and then let everything come from
there you know so there's no one way to
do this but it's like
social media has definitely
put another thing for us comics to do
but oh boo hoo the powers in our hands
boohoo
you know i mean earthquake's funny
because he's from such a different
generation that he has a built-in fan
base
of his generation yeah like he could
anywhere and sell out
for people that don't have instagram
like people that just know him
maybe they're on facebook once in a
while but like he he's kind of like a
kind of kind of grandfathered in to just
like do whatever kind of comedy he wants
it's cool that chappelle uh produced
that special form but like he's he's a
powerhouse you know
yeah for anyone that thought chappelle
was cancelled
netflix is like give them four specials
of course
they don't care they're amoral
institutions they just want to make
money
it's all a sham
um
cm sylvester this is an interesting one
that um
hopefully maybe can tie into your
experience working with uh hassan
because i would love to hear more about
the experience in a writer's room but uh
cm's question is
um
i like to incorporate current headlines
any advice
i don't think regarding
[Music]
reusing headlines too much oh i think
any advice using headlines too much
i mean
i don't know uh
if it's working for you then then i
guess you should keep doing it i'm a big
fan of topical humor i think
it is
very underrated
you know because it kind of gets
pigeonholed into the late night
world
right
like
you know oh you're people look at look
at it like it's kind of corny because
those jokes because of the recency bias
of everything
you can kind of get a laugh that's
easier off of topical jokes
but
two things one as a talent and as like a
skill to like to build up it is super
useful
if you're
pers wanna write because that's a lot of
what what writing for tv is or writing
for even radio or podcasts now have
writers
yeah that will definitely come in handy
but at the same time if you could
broaden that out
and make topical jokes that are that are
still
of the day but are a little bit broader
than the moment you know what i mean so
like a joke that's about
biden as opposed to a joke about
um
something biden just said
if you can make it a little bit broader
i think jokes that are like that are
really powerful because all comedy ages
really badly all comedy no matter what
if you look at it any comedy special
from 10 15 years ago they all
age
and they all look corny
and silly and the comedian is dressed
weird and the comedian is talking about
even if they're talking about ever
so-called evergreen ideas
they're talking about their wife they're
talking about dating whatever these
things that seem to never go away even
those things age really poorly because
as a culture we're all changing so it
all look it always is gonna look kind of
old
i have this theory
that jokes that are a little bit more
topical and are about the the issues of
the day actually age better because when
you watch them you can you know the
historical context of them and they kind
of they taste better in your mouth
because you know
oh bill hicks is talking about the iraq
the gulf war
i know about the gulf war these jokes
make a lot of sense to me because i know
about the gulf war right and it kind of
gives it kind of makes the fact that
he's wearing
clothes of the early 90s and then he's
kind of got this like perspective that's
very 90s it all kind of like it flows
better as opposed to someone else from
like bobcat goldthwait
who you could say is doing something
that's kind of
evergreen like he's doing some wacky
thing
you watch it and you go we've sort of
moved past that as a society like we're
not doing like anybody doing a voice
like that
it just it just feels dated you know
what i mean whereas the thing that's
actually dated jokes about the news
jokes about
you know president clinton
if you know the history of it it's very
enjoyable at least for me i like history
so maybe that's just me but that's my
opinion when it comes to topical jokes
so i would i would actually keep trying
topical jokes
you'll get a lot of pushback though
because people
i mean you know the news is twitter and
stuff people eviscerate every single
headline nowadays so it's like
it's rough to come up with an original
uh bit yeah i like the idea of making it
broad or making it like
somehow personalize it to like
if joe biden said something then somehow
personalized again to like
like your dad's reaction to it or
something to kind of bring it in right
make it uniquely yours
totally to you can turn it into
something that's
uh speaking to a larger issue
than
just that moment you know what i mean
right yeah yeah that's really good
topical humor can do that yeah
yeah what was the process and uh cm said
thanks that's great insight and um
appreciate it sam
i'm just gonna text my wife and let her
know
that i'm not ending uh at six
um
she um not she but when it comes to
working with uh hassan
what i've heard uh a john oliver writer
say that
they get like all the serious out first
just write it out like serious as it
happened what they're talking about and
then humor is like the last thing they
add is what she said but like what was
the process for what you guys did with
hassan
um
yeah so with hussein we we
you know
that that kind of was the case with
with patriot act like we would
have a story get pitched to us by the
news we had a news division at our show
and they would sort of like give us the
basic beats like this is why it's an
issue
this is what we're doing wrong as a
country and like here's what we can be
doing right basically and then yeah then
we would we would go into it and and
try to come up with like funny
riffs writing a show like that is so
it's different from everything else
though because
a lot of the comedy comes from
clips that you find you know
a lot of the comedy comes from and we
would have this database of like tons of
clips
from from all over from local news from
cnn everything it's like got everything
that you could ever want and you just
like search
uh
you know
uh federal reserve
and then you look for something funny
right
so a lot of the comedy would cut which
is very different from from regular
writing
and
you know a funny thing my
because the uh carter talked about the
black panther joke
i actually in my packet applying for the
hassan minaj for patriot act
i
used a clip from black panther
that was the joke to to use it in in my
in my packet i i basically did the bit
in my packet
to make this broader point about
islamophobia
and i think that's partially why i got
the job because it like really worked
um
so clips are just a huge part of it it's
super referential
um
the the funniness
there i mean there were definitely
episodes that we wrote that i wrote that
i did not enjoy writing
99 of the process like 99 of it i was
like this is not a funny episode
this shouldn't be on tv this shouldn't
be a comedy show like i don't know what
we're doing here like there's an episode
about guatemala and uh asylum seekers it
was about asylum seeking really from
from central america
and it was just so dry and and and
and just heartbreaking you know trump
like
ended asylum seeking which is probably
one of the worst things he did you know
people talk about the tweets and stuff
but like he ended asylum like nobody's
allowed to seek asylum in america and
biden has kind of maintained to maintain
that
but we we did it we wrote it me and my
friend moss pericone we wrote it and
then right at the very end we we figured
out some like really silly
um
little little joke ideas and we like
sprinkled them throughout the episode
and and we gave it life you know
but for the most part
we would have one or two joke beats
going into it
for the most part for most episodes you
would have one or two ideas like you're
like i know that will be a big laugh and
that will be a big laugh and then you
build everything kind of around that
yeah and are they for like the topics
you tackle are they basically like all
right this week we're talking about
asylum seekers go like is that kind of
how it would happen
no no so so we had um and john oliver is
like this and i'm sure that there's
probably a couple other shows that have
this process but basically the writers
all we do is like hang out it's a really
cushy position you just hang out
you pitch silly ideas
about um
just like what husson can do for this
and that for for
you know social media and then the news
division puts together these huge books
on
the pro the the topic so for asylum
seekers there's like a 200 page book
full of information about the asylum
seeking process what it used to be like
what it is now
uh you know the going from panama up to
uh uh texas going from mexico all these
different terms and stuff huge book
literally 200 pages
and they would just give it to us as
writers and then we would have to put
together the script based on that
and they would you know they would like
have highlighted things that are
specifically important because these
news people were like they were from you
know cbs and and washington post like
they were legit people
um so they kind of knew what they were
talking about
and um they gave us direction and then
we would write the the whole thing and
with the like little joke ideas
sprinkled in it
yeah
and then
it was then you pitch it to hassan like
or is he part of the writing process or
hussein would be only in the beginning
of the process and the end of the
process for an episode so at the very
beginning we meet with hussein and the
show runner and the um by the way the
show is not on tv anymore it got
cancelled but right
yeah we had a two and a half year run we
did okay and um so we meet with us in
the show runner in the newsroom and the
newsroom kind of gives us the basic
beats of what the story is and like
gives us the book they hand it's called
the handoff we acted like it was a big
deal
and
hudson would sort of like kind of
throw out his ideas and we could go yeah
that's a good idea or we could go yeah
all right we'll we'll put that in and
then not ever put it in um and then we
would go off it was always two writers
to a script so it would be me and a
friend or something
um
and it was just a very it was fun i i
miss that the collaboration that was
really fun
and then we go back to hessen and
he sort of will have the script and
it'll go through a million edits the
head writer will
you know
throw it in the garbage and
out something brand new i'm making
it sound really bad it was it was a fun
time it was fun but that's how you feel
as a writer you feel like oh they just
ruined my script they just made it 10
times worse
10 times less funny and now they're
asking me to make it funny again
um
but that's just how it is you know every
th that's how a lot of writer's dreams
are john oliver's that same way
um
i'm sure there's another one i'm sure
bill maher is something similar i don't
know what bill maher is doing actually
he probably doesn't have a news team are
you just there all day every day
yeah for that job we were there
god for that job we were there like
10 a.m to like 2 a.m sometimes it was
nutty
um
but then it got better because it was
new i joined it when it just started so
everybody was really new like
you know huston and the head writer and
stuff were really like new to having a
show
so
it was rough around the edges for about
a year and then
uh it got really good the second the
second year and a half
it got a lot more
stable you know it'd be like 10 to five
as opposed to 10 to whatever like
whatever needed to be done right right
right um
and that was just a part of the process
of of the show getting better
but all rooms now or for the most part
are um over to zoom now so
i'm in a room right now and it's and
it's yeah i
work three hours a day and and you just
you just have a zoom meeting and you
shoot the with writers and
uh creative people and it's pretty fun
man
and then when it gets canceled is there
like a big group meeting and hosting's
like guys they screwed us
bro that
we got cancelled in may of 2020
and
yeah it was really unceremonious there
was just a huge
just a um
big zoom meeting basically with everyone
with 100 all 100 employees
and they just were like
yeah so uh netflix decided not to renew
us and uh you know it's been a pleasure
but uh we're all gonna we're all gonna
uh land on our feet and uh take care
it was like literally a five minute
conversation like literally maybe less
maybe i remember i woke up got on zoom
and then five minutes later i was like
well
i don't have health insurance now you're
unemployed you wake up and you're
unemployed
yeah pretty much that that was but i'm
sure they were also like going through
it i'm sure they were like
depressed
um
yeah that that was that was rough
because we all thought it was going to
get renewed we all thought like oh here
comes the big staff meeting where they
reveal that we're renewed and it's we
all have to pretend like it's so cool
that we got renewed we all everyone we
all thought we were coming back but
netflix man they're ruthless
oh shots fired
shots fired
you're crazy
why do you say that
because they just
you know i mean all corporations are
basically dictatorships and um
they they they keep their information
secret and you don't really ever have an
idea of like what's going on and and
where your show is how your show is
doing
you you never really know
and
so we just kind of had like a basic idea
that we were doing okay that's what they
told us they were like you're doing all
right like your numbers have like been
steadily going up and this episode did
really well and then they would come in
with it's all it's not like network tv
which is a little bit more analog and
you know the process is a little like
more bulky netflix like they have all
the data on everything so they come in
and they go hey we don't want you to do
this episode because
we want you to kind of focus more on
this kind of thing because that gets
more views and
oh like topics to write about
a little bit i'm not going to say like
that happened a ton but i'm sure it
happened a fair amount like maybe maybe
half a dozen times or they're like they
kind of would give their input i'm like
maybe you want to talk more about this
that's about that
um
yeah it's not it's not
i don't like having a job
so i'm not a really good person to talk
to i'm very negative about anytime i'm
working i feel
it's a blessing you know but it's also
i i'm a stand-up you know so that's like
what i like to do is just i don't want
to be
having to meet people
makes you just want to blow something up
yeah yeah yeah
yeah pretty good
very good that's in his comedy special
everyone which you can watch on the
comedy central youtube channel right
meow
yes it's available right now
so thank you so much for spending your
time and um
sharing the sauce here my friend um
i know we had let me scroll through
these
um
i don't know there's a few questions um
but
we can land the plane here
uh yeah whatever you want to do i i i
i'll have a movie tonight can you do a
few can you do a few questions from the
hot breath verse here
yeah yeah i i yeah i have time
no do it no we don't have to
no
well we
i i mean
i'm already here well we're losing
viewers
that's a good point
okay one more let's do um
let's do rapid fire
30 30 second responses
all right okay
lee sigmund asked how to sound more
conversational and less scripted on
stage
oh
seconds
i don't know man that that's a that's an
experience thing you just got to keep
going up and getting it's comfortable
you just have to get comfortable you
have to get super comfortable on stage
and uh and
not overthink it
and it also helps to like
to practice talking practice talking to
yourself by yourself
to like
oh there's a timer i like that i just
said yeah practice talking to yourself
so that you you can hear it to yourself
don't just write it on the page and then
you'll get more comfortable
boom
just me comedy
how to get over stage fright
oh man
that all right
prop
i mean you just gotta go on stage a lot
i don't know it's like exposure therapy
you got you gotta go this is the same
answer to everything you gotta go on you
gotta go on stage you just gotta do mics
you like we were saying earlier you have
to experience the pain of bombing and
the pain of being
hated and the pain of being viewed as
the worst person at stand-up in the
world
and then you'll get better
boom
stage time it all comes down to stage
time so the next um
marcus mauser
uh i'm doing a five minute clean set
this weekend
um
i can't help but cussing and it just
comes out any advice for writing clean
oh i mean if it's
writing clean like
i mean that's kind of easy you just
gotta you just gotta not use cuss words
is the is the issue that you have to be
talking about and dick like
just don't talk about that just just
talk about other stuff there are other
things in the world you know talk about
politics
and if you don't cuss it it'll make your
writing better it honestly will because
you'll have to think about other ways to
to put things
kaboom
awesome well great well let's end it
right there
uh ishmael it's been a pleasure amen
please let the hot breath verse know
about your special where they can follow
you and
keep up with what you're doing
yeah uh you can thanks for having me man
uh you can have you can find my special
on youtube it's called sound it out
it's my little fee sound it out that's a
comedy central produced special
um
it is uh 30 minutes of comedy some of my
favorite jokes
and you can follow me on instagram at
it's my name just ismail period luke fee
ism ael
and then it should come up period fee
hello utfi and that's that's where i
post all my dates i'll be coming to
gainesville
someday soon maybe i'll get austin you
could open
um but yeah that's it
awesome thank you so much man this was
dope congratulations i'm so excited for
you man it's really cool to see
appreciate it joel
yeah it's great to see you again man and
congrats on doing the pod and everything
thanks everybody all the work you're
putting into it yeah man
it'll pay off
all right doug have a good day buddy
yes that made it all worth it right
there that was dope
all right man thank you my man have a
good one
oh
bye y'all